This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that provides free delivery setup and mattress
removal.
Wow.
Christina
speaking
on 13 size tax,
as I recall.
Dining common.
Those pool.
Yeah.
You like,
I'm circumcise guys.
Geez.
It's like when you,
I recall,
right?
Like he's at a restaurant and the waiter remembers him from last time.
It's exactly what it is.
Yeah.
You like the Chateau Neuf as I recall,
as I recall.
Right.
You like that.
Uh,
uh,
and Endesa is,
I recall my head with the Cabernet as I recall.
If I looked back and a recall,
where's the county?
You know,
here's the guy.
Yeah.
You like uncircumcised guys as,
as I recall,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's so fucking gross is that's a,
that's a male prostitute,
right?
Yeah.
That's the thing.
He's trying to get that money out of this guy.
So you got any common,
those bulls,
that's a different approach than the male to female prostitute.
Like how guys would be women if women would a yeah,
this is 100% how we will talk to you all the time.
Okay.
Walk me through court ship.
If you could just say the stuff he really wanted to say like,
okay,
it's 2005 you and I are at the cat club and we're meeting for the first time.
Go.
Yeah.
I'd be like,
ah man,
I'm trying to nut right.
You mind if I do it all over you or you want to help?
We want to get involved.
Hurry,
touch it.
Yeah.
Put your hand on it and there's your mouth.
Give it to me.
Touch it.
And then what'd you grab my hand?
Come on.
He'd make it happen.
Right?
Like I'm hungry now.
You want to eat something
then?
Yeah,
it'd be like if it,
it would be the way that like two best friends,
like two guys that are Hetero,
that are best friends talk.
That's how it would be if a,
yeah.
So I would just be like,
oh,
that was fun.
Uh,
I don't play video games now.
You want to watch the game?
Uh,
yeah.
Let's get some food.
Do you want to fuck again?
That was what you want to fuck again,
like no social pretense because the yeah,
wouldn't be the dance.
Yeah,
the woman does the romance dance and like the play of,
I just be like,
it feels good.
You mean the actual court ship and the civility,
all that nonsense and be gone and you could actually get down to the real deal,
which is like,
it's hard again.
Can you work it out?
Yeah.
I like how you consider the woman's side of it.
Just like frivolous nonsense.
It is frivolous nonsense to know the other person the worst.
It's the part that every guy dreads because we just want it to be like,
can we just stop with this bullshit talking and getting Taco and then like,
you know,
oh you know,
or you want to make sure I showered,
like all this stupid shit and then you have to act like,
you know,
we're working our way through the steps.
We just want it to be anal and done getting it in.
Well that's why a lot of men say that other guys are creeps right.
Like,
why manner hate other guys.
I don't know.
Guys are such a scumbag.
This is an interesting topic.
I feel like we should just open the show.
I don't know if all guys would like that or not,
but let's just open the show and we'll get into it.
Okay.
Let's just open this show.
Hi there.
Uh,
my name's Pete.
Today I'm going to be demonstrating a new toy that I got and the cool thing
about it is it incorporates a power Israel
and the pledge light and your heart day.
Oh,
don't bring it.
Well,
go to your mom's house.
This guy seems cool.
This is,
this is how guys want to be with you all the time.
All the time.
Yeah.
Do you realize that if guys were allowed to just court the way they want to,
like what you're talking about?
Yeah.
That first of all,
like uh,
sexually transmitted diseases would be rampant.
Yeah.
The population would actually,
I think dwindle because everyone would die,
I think.
No,
I think you're right.
Like HIV would have spread you too.
Like so much faster.
Yeah.
Everybody be a good thing.
There's too many people,
I think.
Yeah.
And like everybody's genitals would just be sealed with herpes sores have so
crestally man fear.
Yeah.
You guys would just,
it would run rampant disease if men could just do it the way they all wanted
him.
Or some women essentially keep this whole thing in check and working course.
Well,
there's some,
there's some scholarly wagons out there that really only lag,
that don't care and are just like dudes.
But yeah.
You know,
then there's decent,
those girls are damaged guts,
you know what I mean?
Of course those girls have,
they have beat right here as the debt
and your hard day
from the 70s.
I don't know,
man.
He's talking about flashlights though.
So,
yeah.
Let's,
um,
do I have to know?
I want to know,
I want to know about this toy boy,
how it works.
Let's see what he did.
Was He what he,
I think he may have built this himself.
I think he did.
I definitely did.
Whoa.
That's a huge one.
And
to help hold it for a really fun drive himself.
I'd be proud of myself too.
I'm proud of,
but that is enormous.
I mean it seems like it's sort of counter productive because it looks like it's
a like a real,
now you're just not thinking of it the way he is.
He can,
he and his friend can put their dicks in there.
Yeah,
I guess so.
It may have your friends over again.
A cool thing to do is hang out with your friends and get your dicks off.
It's a DP here.
If there was no social stigma about that,
that's another thing that they be got would do.
You know if they weren't like in fear of being thought of as you know.
Yeah.
Then every guy would be like,
let's Jack off today.
Right now,
every guy always be like,
why don't we just hang out and come on each other?
All right.
Now do you think that DPS are gay?
What do you mean?
Well,
because you've got one in the pink and one in the stink and then they're like
right next to each other doing grind and do sometimes you DP in the same hole,
but even that's not gay.
Yes,
totally gay.
Grinding Dick's with some days.
I don't think so.
I think you actually have to be like extra
sexually,
you know strong.
You have to be a total stud to do that.
To do that,
to do two and the pink.
Yeah,
because you have to block that out and still focused on her and stay in the
moment.
That's what I'm saying.
So half of your penis is having gay sex because you're grinding to day,
I guess.
I see what you're saying is having Heteros we were half gay.
If,
if it's a vaginal Dhea,
I thinks you're just a total deviant is what you are to be able to do that.
You're not a normal guy.
Right,
right.
No,
no,
you're not.
You're who does that?
Do people really do that in their private sex lives and their private life?
Yes,
but rare two in your veggies and sometimes they go double anal,
double vaginal.
No,
nobody's really doing mad.
Sure they are and sometimes they're going to triple.
Yeah.
I'm writing a story.
I'm running it.
Yes I am.
I am.
I swear to you.
What are you writing his story?
I'm writing a story about the lady who did the first,
uh,
two,
two and two.
What do you mean you're writing a story to scale for what?
To shoot something.
Oh my gosh.
Oh,
and she's talking about her old now and she's talking about her,
her early days.
She's reminiscing but not really reminiscing.
She's saying that she was the first and she's proud of it.
I'm proud of my part of our ourselves.
Jules had two and u three and U.
Yeah.
And she didn't even know until people were like,
you had to and you and you had three incidences.
Iowa.
I'll Paul about buffalo.
I was like proud of myself.
That's really,
it wasn't until uh,
wait.
Yeah,
it was a lot of Dick's,
you know,
ain't nobody got time for today.
It wasn't UNSW hallways that you have to when you have three in years that I was
like,
I forget it out though.
It really is.
I know.
It's so old.
I don't know even know where it is,
but it really is.
It's a lot to have to in your ass.
Well,
even two in your assholes a lot.
But two in Gosh and your virgin is like,
yeah,
but at least you're virgin is made for them.
Your asshole
holds 90 made for not design for any of that.
I can accommodate,
but it's not designed for it.
You're a virgin is at least like,
all right,
you're a genius things.
It's a really big Dick.
It's like Jesus down
to in you.
I don't know.
Do you put the,
is it,
do you think that people really put the dog in the bathtub too?
Of course.
Is that real?
Of course they do.
Yes they do.
You can't put your beans in her too.
Yeah,
you can.
Have you seen it?
I've seen it in movies.
A movie again with a talk like these are not films or movies,
so it was Francis Ford Coppola movie.
I was just watching it the other day.
I forget what it's called.
They shouldn't be called films or movies.
They're not.
It's not that.
It's something different.
It's what people do.
Use a different word.
Let's see this toy and action.
Me Too.
Oh my kids.
No
shame.
Oh my God.
He's jerking off on this,
answered it.
How do you like watching this dude?
He's pretty funny.
Let's see.
Bus does and I just had a really good night.
Take care.
Yeah,
the cleanup,
he did the thumbs up.
The problem with men and sex toys is the cleanup because you know there isn't
any,
there's no cleanup happening.
You know that.
Yeah.
They're just letting that stuff k garb and get grody are and it,
I agree.
That's probably the worst part of dues is how nasty they are.
If he could invent something that had like a,
a condom in it or something and that you could just be disposable,
like diaper bags or something.
Wow.
What'd you hook up with that guy?
No.
What'd you have?
If it was between him and the guy from a few weeks ago,
that's a swinger that talks about Christ.
Ah,
this guy,
because this guy is super stoked on like a toy,
right?
Perverted stuff.
He'd be stuck up in a real angle.
You'd be banging you and he'd be like,
you know Jesus.
No to saying you'd be like,
Oh man,
can we just get back,
hone it?
Honestly,
honestly,
all those law,
I would hate the guys rap.
Like you said,
like he'd have a whole rap.
Yeah.
He'd have to talk to,
I don't want to talk about Jesus or your bullshit like that.
That would kill me.
At least this guy is just straight forward.
Yeah.
He just wants to Jack his dick in front of you,
which is fine.
Right?
That's fine.
That's not even a big deal.
I know.
It's really not.
I've seen so many guys do that.
Everybody's all upset about Louie.
It's like,
yeah,
I've seen guys do that.
Some essence.
I was 12 and public.
Jesus.
I don't feel like it's that scarring,
you know?
Wait,
wait.
Dave Chappelle said in his own [inaudible] personality,
that wasn't much of a dream at all.
Hey,
I heard that right.
Is that Ryan Seacrest's delay?
Latest pervert.
Yeah.
They say he grabbed,
uh,
some pussies or something.
Well,
ladies accusing him of like brushing up with is hard.
Dick on her,
his stylist to stylist,
you know,
come on.
I know if that's what she's accusing him of.
I think he likes guys.
I always thought he's so Faye.
He's not.
He's pretty,
but he likes girls.
He's always been non,
he's gender Pronoun is something else.
Yeah,
no,
I think he likes,
he likes women,
but he's just,
you know,
he's a certain lane of dude.
Very well groomed.
Yeah.
What does that,
that became a term metro service.
Why is that called metro-sexual?
Heterosexual with mixed with a man.
Maybe Maduro.
Male.
Hetero.
A male.
A metro male.
Hetero Homo.
A male.
Hemal Nah,
I don't fuck it.
Now let's Google it it saying,
yeah.
Metro male.
Hetero man.
I don't fucking care.
What is that from the 90s?
Yeah,
that's an old one.
I remember when this young urban,
heterosexual male with liberal political views and interest in fashion and a
refined sense of taste,
but the same.
Where does the word cuddle?
Know what the,
um,
what is the,
let's see,
Metro sexual,
what does it etymology.
Some big word for you.
Good luck.
Sports and Metro meets homosexual.
Okay,
but
metropolitan,
that's what,
that's what the metropolitan,
hmm.
No Ma.
Oh,
it's metro meets homosexual metro.
That's what it's saying.
I don't have to fucking bandwidth today for that.
Mm.
I Dunno either,
whatever.
Anyway,
I would like to say that I was charged with the task of picking up your coffee
today before we started taping and I,
it always strikes a little bit of panic in my heart,
which makes me happy when I have to pick up your drink order because it's very
specific.
And I know last episode we were discussing the three locations that we frequent
and I went to the and valuing good service.
Right.
And I went to the most inferior of the three one,
two and the one that I went to is a drive through and I prefer that because I
don't like to get into the car.
Drive through.
Yes.
That's the one I went to was the one that I told you was exemplary.
He again,
but I'm not going to get out of my third fucking car.
The one in the horrible parking lot.
Oh yeah.
Cause he,
there's also a fourth one.
Where's that?
The fourth one is if you start heading towards the freeway.
Yeah,
that one's better.
I drive.
But that's further from our house.
The problem with the drive through those closest to us is that it's at an exit
from the freeway.
It's a terrible intersection leaving the freeway or entering the freeway.
This is an entrance exit.
And so it is a,
it's a highly trafficked area because of its location.
Too busy.
I know.
And I went in and I have to agree with you Tom,
that this one is the worst.
A,
they're not as friendly,
uh,
be.
I had to repeat my verbal order three times for him to repeat it back correctly
and see they ask,
it's just a splash of,
of home.
So your drink is an iced venti coffee,
a Venti iced coffee,
extra ice and just a splash of whole milk.
That's right now.
And I,
I very,
I specify just a dash.
I don't even say Splat,
a dash of whole milk.
And they gave it to me and it was like blonde and I was like,
and I get back to her,
I go,
listen,
this is for my husband.
He's going to beat the shit out of me if I don't get this right.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Why would you?
Why?
Well,
I feel like you're going to beat the shadow.
Come on.
That's not even cool to put out there.
And I go,
I handed back once and I got more coffee,
please.
This is for my husband.
He likes just so they get it back to me.
It's still too blunt and I go again a second time I go,
dude,
this is still too light,
please.
I'm going to get a severely bit,
my lips going to get split up and you don't even know pregnant.
And he just pushes me down the stairs and then she gave it back.
Still not good.
And a third time,
three times.
Can you kidding me?
I can't bring back an inferior quality product.
I really would love to you.
Thank you for doing that.
Kill me.
Would not kill you.
And her attitude on the third time.
Definitely.
Right?
I mean,
rightly so.
I had three times.
She really hated me by that third time.
It's because of that location at the other one.
You can make any request and they do
it with a smile.
They're just fine with it.
Yeah.
Well,
they listen better,
I feel.
But this,
this poor staff,
I think there's Doug,
you said too many cars.
We've become my dad.
I know with Starbucks way he is with Mcdonald's.
We,
you mean you will listen to you talking about it.
It's only because I'm jumping on your train of lunacy.
You started this.
Yeah.
So you're boycotting the gunnels.
Well I love their coffee back.
It's the best coffee.
Right?
But they've gone to,
to drive two lanes.
Yeah.
And so what happened is,
I mean time did that,
yeah.
The lanes the other day,
it took me 13 minutes to get my coffee to the dresser.
Yeah.
It's too long.
And he end because even though they have two lanes,
they don't process it as fast as they should.
So,
so from a customer point of view,
it's actually attached marker.
And I talked to them about that.
And what do you do when you talk to them?
How have you talked to him or I call it the one 800 and Mcdonald's not burden in
Illinois.
And they're very nice and they,
you know,
they,
I think food generally concerned.
But I've,
I've noticed this and a couple of other,
so now I go to Mcdonald's that have single lines and that you're not,
but you said you were a boy cloud that really boy counting.
But I'm doing it.
But you're boycotting the double lane.
Dual lines,
you know,
in Mcdonald's did not get your business.
Do Elaine Mcdonald's don't get my bonus.
I don't want to go to single and Mcdonald's not because they're,
that one is not convenient for me and I'm not going as much as I used to go to
adorable.
I mean,
yeah,
that's,
you know,
that's from seven years ago.
I can't believe that seven years old,
God,
time flies really does.
And we've been married.
They've been married three years.
No,
I think so.
23 years.
Yeah.
Oh wait,
we've been married 10 years but together and when we,
we haven't really been together.
14 years.
Been together probably four or five years now.
That has been serious.
Cause that was dating.
I was dating six years ago.
I remember.
Hey,
but you were dating up until I got pregnant the second time.
Yeah.
I mean I've still,
I mean I'm not exclusive with you.
When you go to film this movie,
Do you think you'll remain faithful or are we going to do that?
I mean,
I'm five months pregnant.
I feel sexy.
I feel like I'm ready to put myself out there.
Yeah.
What do you want?
How are we going to date other people?
I don't know.
I don't know what's going to happen.
You brought this up this morning that your dad's in fluxion is weird on certain.
Yeah.
He's like,
he did it right here.
I know.
It's like,
and that's a dual lane and
he says at the end he's like,
he'll be like,
mother and I are going to be taking cruises.
We like to cruise.
Right.
Why are you saying it like that?
Like why did you say we'd like to cruise and he's like,
just what we like to do.
He goes right back to work.
He didn't do it.
Yeah.
He hears English.
He speaks English his way and then he hears commonly said words correctly.
It's really weird.
You know what does it auditory?
Yeah,
maybe he should get his ears checked.
Do you think his hearing is?
I think it's a lost cause.
I think just let it go.
Let them 70.
Dual.
So I uh,
value.
Okay.
And do you have a favorite employee?
The single lane.
Mcdonald's.
Like you did it,
the other one?
No,
I haven't really cultivated a favorite employ like it did.
Amanda was my favorite employee.
Was what'd you like about her maximum efficiency.
Okay.
Maximum efficiency and maximum efficiency.
All right.
And uh,
how it goes when you go through the drive through right here.
Dad Too.
When he,
when he comes over here,
um,
he always does this where he taught,
he's like,
okay.
And he like gives you the eye thing?
Yeah.
You have to like agree with him.
He gives you like an eye affirmation.
You're like,
uh,
dualet Mcdonald's and I get my business.
Okay.
And then he pauses and looks at you and you have to nod back.
I always feel the pressure to like affirm when he's affirming.
He has his preferences.
That Mcdonald's one is so weird.
Not Weird.
Obviously it's a very popular place to go,
but I can love Mcdonald's.
Yeah,
I tell you that I've really been holding back the urge to go there.
I want to eat there every day,
but it's not really good for your growing fetus.
Yeah.
No.
What's your favorite item at Mcdonald's?
I haven't been in awhile.
I mean it's definitely breakfast though.
Oh really?
Oh yeah.
Oh,
for like a quarter pounder.
Yeah.
I love breakfast.
You do love breakfast?
Yeah.
What do you get the egg mcmuffin?
Or sausage.
Egg and cheese.
That's a really killer one.
Has a lot of calories,
isn't it?
Yeah.
I try to stay away from there,
but no,
I know we don't
really,
only because of,
you know,
the bread part of it.
The biscuit.
Yeah.
It's delicious.
And they're uh,
that those little fried Hash Brown,
you know,
the how shoes are the best.
That's great.
Get your life always gives me wrong.
It is amazing food.
Two in the morning.
No,
I'm just a few.
We give him breakfast.
No,
cause they serve breakfast 24 hours now.
Oh,
I'm saying if,
and you go there,
any of their food at,
you know,
if you had been drinking is,
nothing's better than Mcdonald's when you're,
when you're,
when you're like done drinking.
Like I eat something that's amazing.
That,
and I used to go to Taco bell a lot.
Talk about,
I know who got me to Taco Bell.
You,
we lived in the Rampart division.
There was one that was near,
they're near our house and that would be like a lot of times my might've been
why I was gaining weight.
I might've been a,
it's like when I would come home at midnight.
Oh stop there.
Ah,
it's so damn nasty.
Last time I had taco bell was what I did.
Uh,
Madison,
Wisconsin
and Madison.
Not the other one.
Sorry,
not Madison.
What's the other one?
Oh,
you do the Appleton.
Appleton.
And I drank red wine and I was hungry and we stopped to Taco Bell and I had a
bean and cheese burrito and a Mexican pizza on top of red wine in my belly and I
laid in bed and I was like,
dear God,
please don't let me vomit.
I will never eat taco bell again.
I felt so sick and that's the last time man,
and that was what,
Oh nine
they're are known for getting people sick.
I know that Twitter feed we look at as Neil Hamburger.
Yeah,
he does a search for like Taco bell and sick and then he retweets really a
fucking hilarious.
It'd be like 30 in a row.
A talkable got me sick as fuck again.
I feel like talk about poison me.
Well,
the meters,
I said the meat is worse,
obviously worse than Mcdonald's meat.
It's like prison grade.
Really pretty bad.
Yeah.
You have to have.
Taco bell is one of those things where you have to mask the quality with heat
piping hot,
so you kind of have the illusion that it's human food because if it cools down
and you really can taste the quality,
any fast food,
really,
that's cool too.
It's not congeals and it's hard.
Mcdonald's too.
I mean that's the worst call.
D you can't even touch a mcnugget past the top point.
Hot,
hot,
hot and nasty.
I'd be like,
is this on fire?
Right.
Either so nasty if it even,
yeah,
if you're going gets lukewarm,
you're like good
and it's,
Mcdonald's always makes my car smell like farts.
Have you noticed that?
Yeah.
Their food smells like fart.
That's all you see their slogan?
Eighties I think Mcdonald's are food.
Smells like Fart.
Dear precious,
delicious.
By the way,
do you want to make the announcements?
I'm on here.
I know some people may already know this who follow me.
[inaudible] chips in a bowl
and
caddied and kibble.
This one's my favorite.
This is for a major announcement.
Announcements.
Oh my.
Such a cute sound,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Makes me miss.
Having a cat.
So go ahead.
All right.
As you know,
being pregnant,
I've been farting out a lot.
Okay.
A lot of times.
Not In my control.
Not a lot I can do about it.
We were eating dinner on Tuesday,
February 27th at 6:40 PM and I was talking meal and I stopped mid sentence and I
farted and I burped at the same time and I will continue talking.
I was like,
so anyway,
and then I go call Tommy.
I just had a double pipe.
Classic.
Yeah.
I just had his own apartment.
Okay.
Cause it happened.
It happened so fast.
Buried
rare.
And even though I want to be there with you and all of these moments to
celebrate and to share in your success,
lot of push back,
what are you talking about of people are going,
hey,
she's pregnant.
You know,
things are going haywire and they're gaming the system if you will.
Yeah.
And they're like,
that doesn't count.
And they really are calling you out because it wasn't too long ago that you were
discrediting people's double pipe classics,
you know?
No,
but only right.
Cause if they're trying to force it by feeding themselves re fried beans or
your,
if you're trying to,
I didn't try to game the system.
This was a natural occurrence.
I,
you know,
I didn't modify my diet in any special way.
Yeah.
Well I don't know a lot of people,
a lot of people were,
oh law that people have did.
They did.
I'm serious.
These people are haters,
you know?
Wow.
Maybe they need to have their own double pipe and then they'll feel better,
you know?
Yeah.
I'm not going to said no video.
No double pipe.
Yeah,
I couldn't.
This is a thing that happens is one of our people,
oh my God,
this guy got you twice did he wrote,
I'm going to have to blow the whistle and say it doesn't count.
Being pregnant with baby gene's number two is obviously if performance enhancing
and more dues,
more bodily awesomeness.
We have heard in previous mom's house conversations that enhancing the endeavor
is a strict grounds for dismissing it.
True double pipe classic is a rarity list and make it common course.
You're going to have to retract that double pipe classic from the scoreboard.
All love.
No.
Hey,
just keeping all that haters on the reel,
we can recognize that the haters was supposed to be the haters.
Yeah.
Much love.
No.
Hey guys.
Yeah,
that's all the hairs writing about a typo.
But I mean he,
um,
he was,
he was very adamant that you didn't,
you don't get what you think you get,
you know,
you don't deserve it.
Is pregnancy and enhancement necessarily or a different physical state of being?
I mean,
look,
if you're asleep and you fart and Burp at the same time,
yeah,
I don't know.
I,
I look,
all I know is it happened and it was so sudden and I was talking to you,
so I kind of wasn't paying attention and just want to say for everybody out
there,
if it hasn't happened for you yet,
don't try to make it happen,
but pay attention when it does.
Cause that almost passed me by.
Yeah.
You know,
I could have,
I almost got out of that moment,
not even realizing
it was pretty amazing.
I mean,
I was sitting three feet from you and I was,
you know,
I mean,
I'm the,
I guess the,
the person that coined the term,
yes.
Even I am in awe of it when I,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
yeah,
it's a how I imagine Steve jobs felt when they'd show them a new iPhone and was
like,
wow,
that was the adventure.
And then it just gets better and better and proofs.
I was at a loss for words.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's how everybody feels when they have,
or they're around ductile pipe.
When's the last time you had one?
I'm trying to,
God,
it's been a while.
It shouldn't happen to you.
You know,
more than once every few years.
I think I had mine two years ago.
The last one.
It takes time.
Yeah.
Really?
Does,
you know what I'm going to,
I'm going to count it as a win.
As a double pipe.
Classic guys.
I,
what am I supposed to do?
It's exciting when Aaron is,
I mean,
you get to make that call.
You tell me.
I mean,
I was there.
I was,
it was,
it was in my face basically.
It seem real to me.
Are you going to say that the pregnancy is,
is it a performance enhancement?
I don't think so.
So passionate about them happening that I don't see it that way,
but I understand that,
you know,
the more successful you get,
you're going to have people that nurse.
Yeah.
Well here's,
here's what I consider to be a performance enhancer.
Okay.
Diarrhea,
because you fart a lot.
So like let's say you're on the toilet with a bout of diarrhea and you're
shotgunning farts and then you burp as you're shotgunning a diarrhea fart.
I don't consider that to be a true double pipe.
Yeah.
If you're gaming the system,
drinking soda and like cramming re fried beans down your stomach,
eating those,
it's still
now it's still very hard to manufacturer.
You're not going to manufacture it.
Your body chooses a way out.
Generally one or the other.
It's like a hole in one when you actually have it go out.
But it's pretty amazing.
Yeah.
Well.
Cause I remember when I farted I had two farts and the first one I just fired.
The second time I farted,
I burped at the same time.
And I remember it felt so different and that's why I pause and I went.
That was a double pipe because it feels different.
It feels weird.
Yeah.
Well it feels different and it feels weird when an angel touches you on your
shoulder too.
You know those are,
that doesn't happen everyday either.
Right?
You just happen to have an amazing thing happened to you.
You should be really at the miracle.
By the way,
I noticed you've been making pizza a lot through your pregnancy and a lot of
pregnant women.
Do you find it to be inconvenient?
Massively.
Would you like a solution?
Sometimes I get jealous that guys can go to the bathroom just about anywhere.
But Ladies Now you can pee like gentlemen to go.
Girl is a reusable silicone funnel that helps you tinkle standing up.
It's made a flexible medical grade silicone that will adapt to your body.
Well,
it's anti spill.
An anti splash design keeps things tidy and mess free.
When we tried it out it was super easy and drip free plus go girl lets you
be discreet.
You only need to address just enough to give go grill coverage.
Nothing too conspicuous and you want to try it.
I would if I were camping like those broad is if you're camping,
can't you just I suppose squad.
Yeah,
but you don't want to squat down where there's ants and bugs and grass and shit.
Like that's why this is idea.
Put this over your badge and it acts as a painter.
Like a funnel.
It's a funnel.
Just a funnel,
but then you ain't,
don't know.
I guess the funnel comes folded in a capsule with an instructional bag.
That way you can rinse,
shake and store.
When you're done.
Besides being medical grade,
the silicone is antimicrobial and it can be cleaned and reused.
Wash it with liquid soap and let it dry.
Washington boiling water.
Or you can even run it through the dishwasher on the top rack.
Yeah,
they're big problem.
What did they don't show you?
Um,
somebody using it.
What can we see someone using it were a cartoon demonstration.
Nothing like that now,
Huh?
Yeah.
So show me somebody actually doing it.
Cause she says,
so you pulled down your pants but then the funnel would have to be pointed out
like a dick.
Yeah.
So that you can point it away from your pants.
Right.
And but I mean as a viewer or as a consumer,
I want to see this thing in action.
I'd like to as well.
But I think my problem with the go girl,
it's just like I said,
like what if the font,
the funnel has to be pointed up and out so that you're not pissing all over your
clothes should do.
They should make that funnel and then have like a foot long dick as the sprout
so that you have a rad chance to get it on you.
But also you can kind of,
it's like kind of a wink at the guy,
you know?
Like check out how big mine is.
Gavi red.
Yeah.
It shouldn't be discreet.
It should be enormous.
Enormous.
Yeah.
I want to carry around a footlong funnel and choose between our 10 12 and 18
inch penis models.
Yeah.
This is good for camping.
Definitely.
Yeah.
Cause it's nasty to squat.
I fucking hate squatting like on the side of the road or whatever.
When you have to pee in and there's no toilets around.
So worst seems like you should try it out.
Try it out.
Try it out top piss on me.
Beat me.
Oh,
I know you've been watching Oj Shelly,
like yeah.
You know what happened often
was,
um,
American crime story,
that FX series.
So this is their second season.
This time they picked the Versace murderer and it is phenomenal.
If you guys are looking for a really,
really good one,
use your FX app or go on iTunes and you can buy it.
You know,
if you haven't been watching it.
Um,
American crime stories,
the name of the series,
they focus on the Versace.
It's really just amazing storytelling.
I think Ryan Murphy is the show runner on that.
Great.
I the kid,
they got to play.
Andrew Cunanan is tremendous actor and it,
and also they got Edgar Ramirez to play Versace and they got,
um,
Penelope Cruz play Donatella sister.
So just crazy.
All Star cast.
But the storytelling device that they use,
in other words,
the way that they lay it out is fascinating.
It's so well done.
And I'm,
I've been so into it,
but you know,
if the show was airing now,
so I have to wait that I went back because I'd never watched season one of
American crime story,
which was the Oj story and that's where they have Cuba Gooding jr playing,
uh,
Oj and,
John Travolta is playing a Robert Shapiro,
Robert Shapiro,
excuse me.
And Nathan Lane plays f Lee Baily.
Really good cast.
And again,
I mean it's all,
it's much more familiar because of how high profile that story was.
But then there's things that I'd only heard a little bit about that they,
you know,
they,
they just lay it out really well.
It's a really,
really good,
yeah,
I picked up,
I was asleep,
but I saw Cuba playing Oj.
I'm like,
they didn't even try to make him look remotely like,
Oh,
Jay.
I know.
But I think it's because he's black and white.
There's no general,
he's a great actor.
Yeah.
So horse.
I mean Cuba is really,
I mean it is only thing that's really weird about that,
his physical stature because Cuba's small short guide.
How would you,
he's a beast.
He's a towering,
oh,
just big dude.
Yeah,
so that,
that part's kind of weird,
but you get over it right away.
I mean,
the only time you ever,
it ever makes it kind of like how your head is when he's standing around other
guys,
you know,
and you're like,
oh,
it's not a small dude.
That story,
Dude.
I remember I,
I,
it was my 17th birthday and I was at a restaurant with my friends and we were
watching Oj get chased by the cops and the White Bronco.
It's still fresh in my mind.
That was 94 right.
And I agree.
And I was like,
dude,
what the fuck?
That would have been 94 94 yes,
me,
my attorney,
I was at a basketball camp at University of South Florida.
That was how,
I mean,
I remember it vividly when when the Bronco Chase happened
and then they covered that story,
man.
Every day on la was the biggest story that Oj murders and the killed Nicole
Brown and Nicole Brown Simpson and the boyfriend and then Kato,
Kaitlyn.
And then you'd see Caito down at the fucking on sunset strip.
Up until a few years ago,
you'd see that guy at comedy shows all the time.
Yeah.
He'd be at the saddle ranch.
She'd be around.
And you're like,
what are you doing,
Bro?
Famous from murder.
Murder.
Like somebody being horrific tube.
Yeah,
definitely murdered.
Yikes.
Yeah.
But we,
but what did you say Oj is up to now?
Well,
I mean a lot of people,
I mean I'm sure everyone remembers,
but you know,
he obviously he was found not guilty.
Then he went to prison for completely unrelated crime.
Isn't that fascinating?
Essentially it was armed robbery of his own memorabilia.
He did a real run in prison.
Now he's out.
And from what I understand,
he's just trying to find the real killer.
You know,
he's out there every day trying to chat that hustle and whoever killed Nicole
and Ron Goldman.
My favorite was the courtroom scene when he's trying to fit the glove on his
hand.
And he's like,
ah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
And He's struggling is so great.
And then he kind of went with it.
Oh like the glove don't fit.
If the glove doesn't fit,
you must acquit.
Must acquit.
Yeah.
It was crazy shit.
That was a crazy time.
The um,
you know,
the race card being like,
it was a total case of portraying,
you know,
using the history of the LAPD.
Yeah.
Cause they had a bad run a couple of years earlier with Rodney.
Well they also had a bad run that good for the previous 40 years.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
It was pretty bad.
And they use,
they played that up so brilliantly as a strategy,
as,
as a way to exonerate him,
discredit all the evidence that was collected
from the homicides.
It's a nightmare.
And you know,
they,
they got him doing this interview for a book where he was just dropping off.
Yeah.
They're like,
he's a racist clearly.
Cause he's,
you know,
saying this
was,
they had,
you know,
had blood evidence on and in the Broncos and they were like,
the cops planted that shit and there was enough doubt.
Those people,
they,
they played it so well and they played the long game with it.
You know,
they didn't just go,
they did this.
It was little by little,
they placed a little bits of doubt.
You know,
they would talk to one of the interview,
one of the detectives on the stand and they're like,
where do you live?
He was like Simi Valley.
And they're like,
oh,
isn't that where the,
the police who beat Rodney King Live,
you know,
so like United.
So they just kept placing those little bits in addition to the big things.
And there was enough,
there was the best part,
the acting.
So you think that these cops just like went out and murdered these people and
then pinned it on Oj and they're like,
yes.
So crazy.
Crazy.
It was absurd.
But you know,
in La,
I think if Oj had been convicted,
I think we would have had another riot.
I think that La would have gone up in flames again cause we had just had riots
in [inaudible] 92 or something.
Anyone I too.
And then 94 Oj.
It was like the best thing be too much for the city.
Was that Oj four part documentary series?
I met that director.
It is,
but it's not a documentary like you think that's why you should watch it.
It's not like here's the case.
It is a true,
it's like a thesis statement.
It is an examination of almost what's unrelated to this story to make the story
happen.
It's fascinating.
It's actually the best documentary I've ever seen.
I think it's called Oj in America.
It's on Netflix.
I don't think it's on Netflix.
I think yeah,
you'd have to download or buy it somewhere.
It used to be,
um,
I think it was in conjunction with the ESPN.
There's what I think is where it aired.
It's so good,
man.
Some documentary or watching as it may have been.
That one,
I caught a few minutes of it where he would stage these things that was on the
dock.
Well he was,
he was folding his American flag and crying and then he had his friend video
tape and it was to sell,
sell that tape.
So there's a moment there,
this is not in the,
in the FX series,
but in the documentary we're talking about,
there's a moment where he's like,
wait,
I think,
um,
I don't know if he's been exonerated yet or,
or what,
or excuse me,
like acquitted yet on the,
on the,
on the crime.
But he's telling his friend and I think he's,
he knows he's asked to move out of his Brentwood house and he's lowering his
flag.
He was like,
stand over here and a kind of record through these bushes and then I'm going to
pull my flag down and like,
I'm really gonna like,
you know,
kind of think about what I'm doing.
And he's like,
then I'm going to notice you and be like,
come on man.
Come on.
Get out of here.
And,
and so he does this whole,
he's like watching his flag come down.
He looks at it really meaningfully and fold it up and he puts it on.
He was like,
oh,
come on man,
come on.
And he,
he waves him off and it is,
and then he's like,
all right,
now take that.
And the guys still rolling on the,
on the Cam quarter right now.
Like,
you can go and sell that and then come back to me.
But then,
so he was trying to get essentially like Paparazzi footage,
you know?
Yeah.
Well you listen to him talk and he's completely checked out.
He's a complete sociopath.
He has a zero.
He's totally disconnected from ever.
He's like,
what was that?
One more time.
Do you ever had a gun he ever held?
He's,
no,
no.
I never,
He said he was never accused of killing anybody.
You know what my favorite thing was too?
I don't remember if this was in the documentary or not crazy for it might be in
the doc in the documentary or it might've been something that I've saw outside
of that when he was serving his prison sentence and for the Nevada robbery,
they said that,
uh,
you know,
after a few years he would come up for parole and there's a,
a parole hearing every time for prisoners,
you know,
you sit there,
parole board sits there,
you have like your attorney,
something else.
They would run through all the standard things,
you know,
your behavior.
It looks like it's this,
I see that you've been participating in that and you've had exemplary this and
that.
Um,
and then they would run through standardized.
In other words,
you know,
the boiler plate checklist questions.
Did you ever go to,
and they would get to,
have you ever been arrested before?
Right.
And they had to like,
it's part of the process and he would go,
uh,
yes.
And they were like,
why were you arrested before?
And he would have to go,
uh,
for a double murder.
And they would,
they'd be like,
what were the circumstances?
Cause that's part of the questionnaire to call.
Right.
And then they would have,
yeah.
And then he,
he would have to be like,
um,
and he would have to retell essentially the whole Oj murder trial story to the
parole board.
And then they'd be like,
oh,
okay,
yeah,
we're not granting you parole.
And then next year he would come back,
they'd go through the whole thing and he would do his charming.
Yeah,
I'm just hitting the juice.
And then they're like,
have you ever been arrested before?
And he's like,
yeah,
like one time.
What was it for?
It was for a double homicide.
And what happened?
I didn't do it,
but uh,
yeah,
it was pretty,
it's pretty big deal.
I think.
You know exactly what everybody knows.
Yeah.
No.
Like,
yeah,
I know.
We know.
But you gotta tell us again.
Damn.
Isn't that unbelievable?
He's really out of his fucking mind.
Yeah.
And that Gianni Versace,
you know,
he,
he was right there on south beach and every time I go to south beach and you see
the mansion there,
it's still there.
Right.
It's still there.
But his family sold it.
Yeah,
no,
a um,
they converted it back,
I think private a hotel.
But it's not like a hotel you can just walk up to.
It's a,
I mean,
in other words,
you can't just see if they have a vacancy you have to book and I think you get
the run of the whole thing.
So it's very exclusive,
very expensive perhaps.
It always occurred to me how,
how high profile that guy was and everybody knew him in the community.
Versace.
Yeah.
He would just,
I mean he literally,
if you've never been to south beach,
it's on that main drag.
What's that?
Lincoln Boulevard or ocean?
Ocean.
Yeah.
And you know,
he just has a couple of gates air on.
Boom.
You're right there on the street.
And that's a major drag.
And we're talking restaurants,
bars,
nightclubs.
Like it's,
it's the main strip there.
Yeah.
It's like living,
um,
on sunset boulevard.
Yeah.
Tourists.
And like everything,
and no one really,
you know,
fucking with us well until right.
Yeah.
But before that he was like,
he loved living there.
He had this,
it was a hotel and something neighboring and he bought them both and converted
all into his rest or just a steak cheese if you ever,
you can look it up or Versace Miami beach home and it's kind of like a jaw
dropper of a,
of a property.
And he would just walk down and get all his,
they said is,
so you'd go to a,
I think news cafe and buy magazines and newspapers in the morning and then walk
back and people would say,
they said people would just pick,
oh,
you know,
they,
he was the most famous resident kind of thing.
And people would notice him say hi,
but not really bug them.
Yeah.
Plus it's a big gay community.
So he was a part of that,
like,
you know,
it was,
it was his community,
whatever.
I just bums me out that John Lennon was a similar way and he got fucking price.
Imagine John Lennon,
Jesus,
uh,
what was that place called?
It's in New York,
starts with a d,
the building forgot what it is.
He got shot in front of.
Yeah.
I don't remember that.
He lived in a place in yoga would go to the movies.
Like I think in New York City people left him alone enough that he could kind of
have a normal life and not be completely flooded with fans.
That's what it's called.
Yeah.
Until one,
you know it takes one psycho,
which is so horrible.
Yeah,
I know.
It's really sad.
My,
yeah,
and he was at I Versace was at the height of his fame and grind and Dex left and
right.
Just having knows having just huge success and the brand promise and really sad,
you know,
he killed him in the thought.
I mean it's sad to get murdered anytime,
but
he just like destroyed a whole family and legacy and company all in goal.
One moment.
That's cool.
Thanks dude.
Well was Charles topics.
He is a nice part for you guys.
I hope you like it.
It's a late Ballantine fart.
Download scribe and let me know what you think about my fart.
Sure,
please give it a big thumbs up.
You guys ready?
Here we go along.
She holding it for
Oh yeah,
that was the best part ever.
No I don't,
you know she talked a lot before.
We really crazy.
That was going to be something.
I don't believe that it's real is,
I think that's real.
It just wasn't up and coming youtube up and coming.
Who goes by the name Kai's see a I z.
She does random videos about her day to day.
Um,
but she also does fart videos.
She said that was the best part ever.
I just don't,
I,
it's not the best part I've seen.
Well this is also a different standard here on the show.
We,
we go with guys like king ass ripper.
Preferential starters.
Yeah.
I mean this chick is fucking amateur Tuesday.
Let's see if she steps it up.
She does a lot of pre
and I wasn't that good.
See and King asked for.
So in his game,
he can't talk a lot before the FARC comes.
He does the set up,
but they're feeling,
she's trying to manipulate an audience.
It'd be like she's trying to say,
hey,
subscribe,
comment.
It's like,
it's like focus on your farts.
More focus on what pays the bills.
Content content is king.
You guys like my new fart.
Please comment down below.
Let me know what you think and please subscribe to my channel.
But I do like
that.
That's a better setup.
Was she just day that says comment on my part?
I feel like that's pretty funny the way she goes.
You like my new fart.
I liked that too.
And I actually like the fart and then the,
the sales pitch,
you know what I'm saying?
Give the audience some content and then the sales pitch you my new car.
I hope you like my new video that,
that I just put it out there.
I spent a lot of time on this guys.
I hope you like that.
Did you like what I just did.
What happened?
Sicko.
She's not looking for dates.
Definitely she's not looking at Yale Nus cause we keep hearing from people that
want to talk to us about their,
their farts.
The far fetish.
I don't know.
I know we've been getting to know people.
I could talk to you about it,
but I think I get it.
I get it.
I don't even mean to do an interview about it.
I don't need to go in depth.
I feel like we understand.
The one guy told us one time,
I forget we were somewhere in Texas and the guy goes,
yeah,
what's exciting to me is the pretty girl in the dirty thing.
But also because of that whole,
you know,
I think it happens in childhood,
but guys here more like girls don't fart and stuff like that,
you know,
because guys are encouraged to be gross,
but then they're like,
but you know the girls aren't so some little boys at a certain point it actually
probably think,
oh girls don't fart
so dumb
all the time with my dad glasses on.
But could you imagine being married to someone?
You don't Fart for a few months,
the beginning,
oops.
And then you're like,
Hey,
I'm going to really let it rip now.
Yeah.
But I feel like lately I've been farting
and then you fart.
You push it out to you.
We've definitely been showing me up lately.
I mean,
I think there's pregnancy is,
yeah,
it's definitely,
tiny jeans.
Jeans is definitely in there doing his thing.
Tj,
each LJ and Tj is what we've decided on.
Tiny jeans.
A little jeans.
Yeah.
Cj's definitely cooking the jams with you.
You know what's great is that our son has finally picked up on how disgusting we
are.
He's been looking for boogers and
we've been teaching them all that good stuff.
Boobies,
boobies,
brokers.
He points at your belly is his baby this morning he pointed at mine and said,
baby,
it's like,
oh shit.
Yup.
Looks like there's a
baby.
It's really funny.
It's a dorm.
Yup.
Cute little kid.
He sure is.
Um,
what else?
You got any clips?
Tell you what I got right here
guys.
Think about my fart comment.
Think about my cycle.
What do you want it people comment.
What is this?
This is Christina's dad is singing.
Is Your Dad saying here?
Here he is.
Not a day.
United States.
United States is a lot.
In those days
they say even line
Sayville saying save alive.
I was trying to say staying alive.
Oh Huh.
Huh.
His teeth look great.
Yeah.
All five of those.
Those are all good.
Uh Huh.
That's good.
I don't know how this got in here.
I really don't.
I like,
I know like I lie.
You think your dad recorded himself then send it in to blue man.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
That's it.
My Dad loves to go on the desert and just sing.
Hmm.
What an interesting background choice to sit in like desert rocks and this guy
is really doing it.
He's had a lot of sun,
a lot of other things to it.
Yeah.
I don't think son is his biggest concern,
but um,
man that has,
he's probably lived a full life.
Yeah.
So you think this is his go to song all the time.
So the person would be cameras like to staying alive again.
He loves staying alive.
Yeah.
This is jam.
And the way that he does it leads me to think that it's his,
his,
uh,
you know,
his performance thing where yeah.
Says go to jam.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's a nice teeth.
So yeah,
you're the base data.
You guys did it.
We made it
and I went,
oh,
I'm by.
No,
no.
Watch Damon.
Go and buy those days dad.
So that your name is Diane [inaudible].
Okay.
Ooh.
Flew those teeth.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
There's one,
two,
three,
four,
five.
There's five.
Yeah.
Is that four or five?
No,
that's fine.
There's a chicklet in the back.
God Damn.
Damn.
Oh see I was seeing a one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
five.
Yeah.
Stumps.
You can,
you can do a lot with five teeth.
You wrap everything about that.
You can't do a lot.
You can do a lot.
Five's a lot of detail.
It's fine.
You can bite into almost anything with five t.
Well shit,
I'm in.
Our baby had five.
They're on the pureed stuff.
He can't give.
You can give it a cleaning basket.
It's not what you want.
Yeah.
I think you want more,
but I think five is plenty.
Yeah,
five too many.
Huh?
You don't need them,
you know one,
one is really
is the minimum of what you need.
I know that's obvious,
but once you're in the fire,
this guy basically has access teeth.
He could donate,
here's what you need.
You need Maulers.
Yeah.
You really only need those molars and the front teeth to bite stuff as actually
like if you had to do the like a a minimal layout.
Yeah,
I would say ideally to here.
Yeah.
And then yeah,
a colon Waller's that's it.
That's kind of it.
Cause the rest of them like do you,
you don't really chew a lot with like at the vampire teeth and with these here I
feel like they're kind of a necessary and then it's a matter of do you feel like
this is what the look you want or not?
Well,
definitely it's luck.
Ooh.
What do you think smells worse?
His mouth or his asshole.
Oh,
mouth hundred percent.
1000%.
There's all types of decay.
You know,
his asshole isn't decaying,
it's just shitty.
But this has active bacteria,
um,
things that are rotting in and around the mouth.
Yeah,
it's bad.
It's not good at all.
It's really bad.
How much do French spells like sick sickness and death?
How much the French him?
No.
Yeah.
I would get,
I would tip him if he sang that song though.
That's a real bummer.
He made up a lot of the words she made up all of them.
But even staying alive wasn't right.
Cause what did he call it?
Same.
The mom.
I don't know.
It was nuts.
Damn.
Save a life.
Save.
Align.
Why is he saying save a life?
Okay.
Is there United way United States United States
say even line.
No.
Sorry.
The line's stable line.
You've got the sound of it.
Write the melody.
Yeah.
Rice video.
By the way,
it's labeled using login.
It says
the video title is.
Oh,
okay.
Tell me.
I'm going to pee too.
Is using long infection like insurance.
Okay.
Wait.
Using lung and get some more like an instrument.
That's the name of this.
Yeah.
Oh,
the back of my head hurts.
I think blue band titled it that.
That's the funniest.
That's the hardest you've ever made me laugh.
Blue Band.
God Damn Dude.
So nasty.
He named me.
He names the files.
Yes.
This first one's called
staying alive.
This one's called closer.
Look at
this one.
He's got red though.
And this is called using the lung infection
man
lung infection.
Dingleberry ms,
I can't read.
Hold on.
Dingleberry mishap.
Hey jeans.
So I was recently taken a massive brown at Chili's.
I thought I shook all my dingles out,
but when I stood up to grab some toilet paper,
a Barry plugged in my underwear and splattered.
How do I go upon living my shitty life after this brown incident?
Most importantly,
what would this even be called?
Try it out.
Piss on me.
Dylan.
Dingleberry like you said,
a piece of shit landed in his underwear is what he's saying.
I guess that's what it beat me.
Try it out.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno.
The Dingle Berry plopped in his underwear.
When I wipe our son's ass,
that happens all the time.
Like a piece of shit will fly into the clean diaper or the dirty diaper.
Yeah,
I mean
I just feel like you got it.
You know,
you got to start doing,
you got to take those wet wipes with you.
The worst thing ever.
Once you have optimum clean asshole at home?
Yeah,
like we do with a day or the water.
What is it?
The water.
There's a name Washlet washlet once you have that and you have this just premium
asshole,
you realize that in public you're fucking,
you're an that's disgusting.
And you know,
I do think sometimes it's like,
I'll try to wet paper.
I was working out yesterday at the gym and I had tucked us the sauciness
sloppiest dump and I was in there as much a flush six times on the clean up.
It's a small gym.
They're like,
you should there.
Why don't you just come home?
We live around the corner because I was about to start with the beginning.
Sorry,
I didn't realize.
So yeah,
I just was like fuck.
And I just kept,
I mean I would walk over to the sink,
wet paper towels clean.
It was horrible.
It's a lost cause you got to just throw in the towel and shower at that point.
I know,
but it was,
you know,
I just got there and I was getting rid of,
you can't,
no,
I'm just saying if you were home I just fucking shower.
Yeah.
I mean I would suggest doing,
we're Tom said getting some wipes or just get yourself the word pushy or
something like that.
They sell the walk around once for like when you go out they sell a pouch with
like five.
Yeah.
God,
it's not a bad idea bro.
Okay.
Pack them before cause they send us some,
um,
I forget who it was.
I think it was a,
what's it called?
Dollar Shave Club.
Yeah,
they make a good one.
So I,
I packed them once and they are great,
but yet you'd have to get in the habit of bringing it with you,
but it's really necessary.
Yeah.
Otherwise you've just have a dirty ass hole and you have
no,
I would suggest first of all,
if you can put yourself on a doot schedule.
Yeah,
that's what I mean,
pregnancy aside.
And what I like to do is I wake up in the morning,
I have my cup of coffee and I,
it's like fucking brown lightning.
Yeah.
I'd take a shit.
And then I shower.
I go straight from the toilet to the shower.
But this is what this is about.
What happens when you're not home?
Yeah,
I know,
but I don't take,
I try not to take shits in strange places.
I know you said,
you know,
this is like sometimes it happens,
sometimes it does.
But you know,
fuck.
Let me ask you this.
Can you kick my ass?
Um,
so here's a question.
You're a prostitute.
Yup.
What is,
it's work,
you know,
it's not just doing the,
it's not just the sex act.
It's really about how do you have your business growth.
In other words,
what is your sales pitch when a gentleman drives up and you're a street walker.
Okay.
What would you say as far as like,
you like big tits?
Yeah.
That's kind of go with your mom.
Like I would go with what stands out most about me.
Okay.
Let's put,
I am pulling up.
Yeah.
Looking out the window.
Maybe you liked these quadruple d tits.
Yeah.
Well come on.
You and you want to take a ride on these tits.
20 $20 I don't know what the rate is.
Let's go over again.
Your car.
How much I know.
I wouldn't tell him the money up front.
Never.
Never go with price up front.
You have to,
what do you mean you have to,
you have to sell the guy.
If the guy wants to know,
he's like,
how much is it?
Oh boy.
He says,
how much you want to come on these tits?
$20 wow.
That's a good deal,
right?
Yeah.
Great.
And that's how I lure him in.
Well,
great.
Let's go to the hotel around the corner or wherever you do your business.
That's what I would do.
I would lure him in with the $20 come on my tits and then I would up the ante
once we're in the room.
That's how you shark.
I'm old baby.
You want to get inside this virgin?
I'm pregnant.
That's a specialty item too.
That's true.
Then I would,
you know,
then I would bring him through the menu,
but 20 is 20 is the entry point because that's not going to make it good.
You gotta you gotta be,
you know,
you have to be willing to do something for that 20 he's going to come on my
tits.
That's not enough.
No,
that's great.
That's great.
For some guys,
that's a big deal.
I'm not arguing with you.
So here's another pitch.
I'm just going to,
I was getting your pitch to show you a pitch.
Oh,
okay.
Chuck on the gang.
Wow.
She rehearsed that line down.
I wish I will.
Here's what I will critique on her performance.
If we're going to go for like an American idol kind of thing right now or the
voice.
I didn't lie.
I didn't believe her because she was too dead behind the eyes.
I feel like maybe her spirit is broken away from,
I would have liked to feel more of a connection to her performance,
but I like the,
now you're speaking as a casting director,
right?
This is as a performer,
performer,
performer.
Then the guy,
he liked that pitch as much.
She asked her to say it again.
I got that deep like the ass lick the balls with that weight on my throat.
Choke on a Gig on a catchy slogan.
The 460 how can I just use the APP
that's on in there?
How many show on the street?
Oh wait,
you're on the street is 20 she does that for 20 bucks in the street.
Right?
She's like,
if I meet you on the streets,
$20 no,
I wouldn't.
I wouldn't go that low for a blow job.
No Way.
She said she swallows it too for half dollars.
No Dude,
no man.
No,
no,
no.
That's pretty wild.
But I do like the rhythm of the,
I got that porno star had I do the thing of is done like that.
Well,
you could also wrap your menu.
You know what I'm saying,
$20 for a street blowjob.
$40 to take it in the hotel.
$60 to get my anal $8 for the round the world.
Whatever you could work on wrapping your filet of fish.
You know what I mean?
Like that old Mcdonald's wrapped quarter pounder flivver and McDonald's,
it Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
You have it all laid out and the guy can pick what he wants from that menu.
But I feel like that's how you low ball yourself.
Cause this cheap mother fucker is always going to pick the lowest.
Sure.
The key is to get them somewhere else.
And then upsell.
We learned that from the cat.
What's that fucking Cat Rach?
What's that fucking dumb show?
Dennis?
The F the Douche bag
where the teeth cat cat house.
Yeah.
That,
those,
those slots were so smart they would get the guy in the room and it was,
well here's the menu already.
Yeah,
yeah.
And then she give him the laminated menu.
Right.
Well baby for $20 I can touch it,
but for $40 you could put it in my,
you know?
Yeah.
And then the best would be the guy be like,
man,
I would see this.
The uh,
just the emotion where the guy was like,
yes.
And she's like,
great.
So then with that kind of party,
it's 200 and then for this it's 800 yeah.
And then he's like,
well,
I just kind of want to,
you know,
shutting your mouth,
put it in.
Okay,
so that's $1,200 she's like,
um,
and you could see him and be like,
sit in the hot tub.
She's like,
yeah,
that's $400 all right.
And then he'd be like,
I thought I have,
and she'd be like,
cool,
we can sit in the hot tub.
We should know.
And she would get like $400 for the guy to be like,
yeah,
you got nice tits.
Yeah.
The best part too is data.
Always take the credit card before any party happened.
Smart goal.
If he goes like,
yeah,
yeah.
Then the credit card,
I'll be right back.
Wait here baby,
take her clothes off or whatever.
And then she would take the credit card to the Madam.
The MME would rang it up,
make sure the credit card was good.
Okay baby.
We're all ready to go.
And then there was a timer.
Remember you got 30 minutes,
let's go.
Let's party dirty.
And then,
yeah,
if they wanted longer,
great.
Give me your credit card again.
And then she'd go out.
Always get the money before the trends I saw when I was home and I did the same
thing.
What's your pitch?
Um,
I'd be like,
uh,
you like,
circumcise Cox and common balls.
I got it.
Um,
it's not going to last long,
but you know,
like showered today.
You want it?
It's hot.
Yeah.
Well you would appeal to the bear,
the bear loving demographic.
You're a bear.
I'm scared.
Oh my God.
They wouldn't tear you apart,
those guys.
I know.
Jeez.
I'd be like,
I'm a new cub.
Yeah.
Right.
Yeah,
right.
They'd be like,
yeah,
you're ready now.
Oh.
And uh,
that would be,
it would be a lot.
I would be pretty skin.
Should be.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's a mess.
That's a genius.
Yeah.
I think all that stuff's just going to be so painful.
I think so too,
but stuff,
you know.
Jeez.
All right,
gene.
Um,
we got to split.
Yup.
Gotta run.
This was a lot of fun.
I like doing these old school ones with you need to,
I like you.
You're my friend.
Haven't heard this song yet called fall.
Fall.
The diapers.
Hmm.
By Dj show reference.
Okay.
All right.
Um,
thank you all for listening.
Please go to your mom's house,
podcast.com Christina p online.com.
Tom Segura Dotcom.
There's also a store on my site that will take you two are merged store.
If you're interested in getting the zip up Hoodie.
Not Los Angeles shirt,
not Los Angeles shirt.
The mugs,
tee shirts.
There's new stuff coming all the time.
Uh,
try it out,
you know.
See if you like it.
Thanks.
Hi Guys.
Hi Jeans.
Try it out.
Sure.
No,
that's fine.
You got to do the word secure.
Just dry.
Wipe your babies.
That's another fucking fortune $50 too.
Back purpose.
Purpose
for Trojan
words,
Bro.
Huh?
All
right.
Can
it be reused.